away from China's bustling cities a
crisis is mounting in rural areas that
will impact the entire country
by the time China's children reach
working age a third of them will be
intellectually stunted in rural China
50% of eighth graders score below 90 on
IQ tests according to the 2010 census
only 24% of China's labor force attended
high school with China's booming economy
placing new demands on its workers
economist Scott Rozelle asks what do you
do with 400 million people in your labor
force who can't learn right I mean they
can't switch jobs this problem of
healthy cognitive development especially
among China's rural population which is
about 60 to 70 percent of its babies is
the biggest problem China faces that no
one knows about to tackle this problem
Roselle established collaborations with
researchers and institutional partners
to form reap the rural education Action
Program the group first tried to boost
test scores by improving children's
health they conducted surveys in rural
areas and found that 27 percent of
children were anemic which is an
indicator of malnutrition 37 percent had
intestinal worms and 20% had myopia the
researchers realized that any one of
these factors would obstruct education
if you're sick how can you learn reap
provided students with vitamins
deworming treatment and corrective
glasses sure enough their math score is
improved
far more than their peers who didn't
receive interventions these findings
helped convince China's central
government to establish a school lunch
program in 2011 that now benefits more
than 20 million rural students daily
there's a giant body of evidence showing
that it's the first 1,000 days that sets
the stage for later educational
achievement and adult health so Rose
Elle's team started focusing on children
in the earliest stages of life in 2013
they tested 1,800 babies from 348
villages in impoverished areas of the
kindling Mountain region 49% or anemic
and 29% scored below normal on a
standard intelligence assessment for
babies called the Bayley test but this
time when the team intervened with
vitamins test scores didn't improve
they're entering a time when you know
they should be starting to learn other
things but with very low levels of
cognition
that's when Roselle turned to parenting
as the possible culprit in 2014
Reap started asking caregivers how they
parented just a third reported playing
with or singing to their child
11% had told a story to their child the
previous day and less than 5% had read
to their job reap then studied 513 child
caregiver pairs half received in-home
parental training which involved weekly
coaching for six months the study found
that the training brought Bayley scores
up to normal but only when the mother
was present with many mothers leaving
rural homes to find jobs in cities 30%
to 40% of rural children are raised by
Grandma when a grandmother received the
in-home training however the child's
Bailey score barely budged the trainer's
had trouble reaching the children and
their mothers in these remote regions
and the process was time-consuming and
expensive the in-home visits did little
to relieve the isolation of kids whose
mothers weren't in the picture what's
more a questionnaire filled out by the
mothers who did remain with their
children suggests 40% of them showed
signs of depression to overcome these
obstacles reap has embarked on its most
ambitious experiment yet the team has
targeted 100 villages in the kindling
Mountain region and set up early
childhood education centers in half
there's free play group activities
reading and one-on-one parent training
they are following 1200 baby caregiver
pairs to see how a stimulating
environment and effective parenting
shape the intelligence of young children
we went in one generation from everyone
raising who they thought were to be
subsistence farmers and now we need to
raise college kids and that's true in
Latin America is true in other
middle-income countries unless you get
zero to three right there's gonna be
huge huge problems the first assessment
of the childhood education centers will
be completed in early 2018 if their
interventions are successful Roselle and
his team hope to convince Chinese
authorities to scale up and establish
early education centers nationwide
[Music]
you